a mere 11 months to the day since
President Trump took office Isis has
been defeated in Iraq and Syria not bad
also grandstanding empty head Charlie
Rose has been fired for sexually
harassing women after months of
haranguing Trump for saying naughty
words about women to Billy Bush we will
catch you up on the latest Democrat
sexual assailants to be exposed pun very
much intended Bradley Devlin and Elisha
Kraus and Amber Athey joined the panel
of deplorable zs-- to talk the DOJ is
investigating Harvard for race
discrimination over its affirmative
action policies how the era of sex spots
is upon us finally and BLM activist
Shaun King's idiocy how redundant I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
we have a lot to talk about today and
one thing I do want to mention though I
mentioned this at the end of the show
yesterday that another Kingdom my
narrative podcast with Andrew Clavin
that he wrote and I perform and it's the
last acting role I'll ever have in
Hollywood that it's doing really well in
the charts on podcasts it's got you know
tens of thousands of downloads per
episode and I think it's got over 700
five-star reviews believe it or not a
major Hollywood producer that I can't
disclose on the show is interested in
taking on this project so more than ever
I really need you to send this to your
friends and keep reviewing it and
sharing it and whatever because I think
we might actually be able to ran this
down Hollywood's throat and that would
give me immense immense pleasure as
Hollywood is lying in rubble to force a
project by conservatives and performed
by conservatives on them so please do it
go over to Andrew Kendrick Levens
another Kingdom where ever fine fantasy
right-wing conspiracy podcasts are
downloaded okay into the news
Isis is over that's some news I guess
that it was pretty quick wasn't it
mattis general mattis told us back in
April that Trump had given him a mandate
to annihilate Isis and now guess what
Isis is annihilated Iraq president Prime
Minister rather hadir al Abadi and
Iranian president Hassan rouhani
announced victory today for those with
short memories Isis developed in 2013
during the Barack Obama administration
in the power vacuum created by Barack
Obama's very stupid decision to pull
American forces out of Iraq but in
fairness to Barack Obama how could he
have known how could a bomber have known
that pulling troops out of Iraq would
lead to the rise of an even more
dangerous threat than we were already
fighting our nation deserves a serious
debate about Iraq because the outcome of
this conflict will have enormous
consequences for our country
failure rack would allow terrorists to
operate from a safe haven with access to
the world's third-largest oil reserves
very Iraq would increase the probability
that at some later date American troops
would have to
to Iraq to confront an enemy more
dangerous and more entrenched failure
Iraq was sent an unmistakable signal to
America's enemies that our country can
be bullied into retreat America's
involvement in Iraq does not have to end
this way what a dummy huh what I can't
believe anyone ever believed that guy
you know that guy that just perfectly
predicted every single thing that would
happen after he left office yeah you
know that guy even predicting what his
opponent Barack Obama what his political
opponent Barack Obama would end up doing
and all of the terrible things that
followed from that what did we get just
a few years later let's take a look this
is James Wright folding an American
citizen of your country as a government
you have been at the forefront of the
aggression towards Islamic state there's
a plot against us and that was jihad
John and we tolerated him beheading a
lot of Americans Americans james foley
steven sotloff peter kassig among many
others were gruesomely beheaded by Isis
on Barack Obama's watch though the most
chilling actually may have been Isis's
simultaneous beheading of 21 Coptic
Christians who were crying out their
belief in yeshua on a beach in tripoli
while Barack Obama was apologizing for
the Crusades or whatever other nonsense
he was doing an office Isis also shot up
a Tunisian tourist resort killing 38
Europeans he bomb rather Isis bombed
Turkey and killed 33 crashed a Russian
airplane killing 224 bombs Turkey again
they kept bombing Turkey the bombed
Beirut attacked Paris killing 130
civilians bombed Istanbul Brussels
killing 32 nice killing 86 attacked
Kabul killing 80 Berlin killing 12 st.
Petersburg killing 15 Manchester killing
22 and many many other attacks after all
with all that weight of evidence how
would Barack Obama describe the group
[Music]
America's deadliest enemies his choice
of war is getting a lot of attention in
an interview with The New Yorker
magazine it compares groups linked to
al-qaeda to an amateur basketball team
quote the analogy we use around here
sometimes and I think is accurate is if
a JV team meaning junior varsity team
puts on Lakers uniforms that doesn't
make them Kobe Bryant end quote
doesn't make him Kobe Bryant they're
just the JV team isn't that what Barack
Obama did this from the beginning of his
campaign onward he was operating under
the belief that if he would say things
that would make them true he clearly
suffered from some version of narcissism
and very frequently he would just say
things that obviously didn't comport
with reality but nevertheless he said a
lie often enough told will become a
truth what exactly did he mean by the JV
team we think we have an idea but he
goes on and explains it in another
interview what I do insist on is is that
we maintain proper perspective and that
we do not provide a victory to these
terrorist networks by over inflating
their importance and suggesting in some
fashion that they are an existential
threat to the United States or the world
order yeah you know they're not what how
would they be an existential threat
they're the JV team they're not wreaking
havoc all over the entire globe and
destroying a region destroying two
nations in a region and challenging
American credibility they're the
existential threat is crucial here
because we're talking about an ideology
that has been encroaching and fighting
the west for 1,400 years
we're talking about political Islamism
and Barack Obama for whatever reason
refused to see that as an existential
threat to the West he he also famously
made fun of Mitt Romney for saying that
Russia was the greatest geopolitical
threat probably because Barack Obama
thinks the greatest threats are from
within or something he couldn't seem to
identify an actual geopolitical threat
to the United States
because he didn't consider them an
existential threat he didn't pursue them
here's Barack Obama explaining that
strategy says that what you have on the
ground now is not going to be enough
every couple of months you're going to
be faced with the same choice back down
or double down I think what is true is
that this has always been a multi-year
project unbelievable mealy-mouthed this
is what happens
by the way when I'm late writing a piece
or writing up a show or god-king Jeremy
boring or ben shapiro they come to me
they say where's the peace I say look
look look this has always been a
multi-year project look this has always
been we just need strategic patience we
just need to lead from behind but
clearly he had no interest in fighting
Isis whatsoever we don't know we know
that he wanted to be a domestic policy
president we also know that he failed at
every level when it came to foreign
policy let's bring on our panel to
discuss the failures of Barack Obama one
of my favorite topics to discuss we have
amber Athey we have Bradley Devlin and
we have the Daily wires own Alicia Kraus
thank you all for joining amber why
would Barack Obama not destroy Isis
apparently it wasn't that hard
apparently it only took 11 months when
we decided we actually want to do it
why didn't he care I think there's this
weird kind of political correctness from
the left where they're actually afraid
to speak strongly to our enemies and
that's become even more apparent since
Donald Trump has taken office because
people kept really upset at him when he
uses strong language towards Isis or
regimes like North Korea um you'll
remember when he got in that Twitter
spat with Kim Jong hoon the left was
freaking out worrying about a nuclear
war so in some senses they're more
worried about the language that they're
using rather than actually defeating our
enemies they are concerned with language
because they think that they can speak
reality into existence city the
appearance is the reality but of course
that isn't the case the reality is the
reality and when you use a language that
doesn't comport with that eventually
people are going to stop believing you
you can't do that forever
Bradley Bush predicted it Obama
completely lost control over it and
Trump defeated these guys why are
Democrats so bad at foreign policy in
the last 20
I can't answer that question this is
really hard it's a tough way it's a head
scratcher exactly and the interesting
thing is Republican presidents have been
fairly consistent with their foreign
policy since the Reagan era the
greatness of the Republican presidents
is that they understand that their
generals and the individuals on the
ground will always be better at
assessing the situations and so what
Trump has done has delegated that power
back to his gentleness and what have we
seen in 11 months isis is taken down in
six months we declared victory in mosul
and we took back one-third the territory
that they gained in 2015 under the obama
administration so i believe there was a
lot of disingenuous attempts to spread
democracy and well Sony and Democratic
peace theory through the Obama
administration we're no longer going out
in building nations we're going out and
defeating terrorists we can't build
nations if the pre conditions to build
the nation don't exist but so the way we
do that is fine whatever surely if we're
talking about Wilsonian democracy and
making the world safe for democracy or
whatever we do have to bring up mr. Bush
jr. that was that the rousing second
inaugural of George W Bush was like a
religious sermon on freedom and freedom
around the world
how much blame should we put at george w
bush's feet and how does he compared to
barack obama well I think you saw
Hillary Clinton tried to do that a lot
and put the blame on Bush for Barack
Obama pulling out of Iraq Barack Obama
was supposed to renegotiate with the
Iraqi government on how many boots we
were gonna keep on the ground and how we
won't maintain peace in that region by
limiting the terrorists impact and Bush
does share some of this blame but not to
the extent that Barack Obama did because
Bush as you showed in your monologue
predicted all of these events if we were
to abandon Iraq and
wilsonian foreign policy aside trying to
spread democracy abroad aside there is a
big difference between George W Bush and
Barack Obama and that's one demonstrated
political courage and one demonstrated
political cowardice when Brahe when
george w bush rather ordered the surge
in Iraq in 2007 it was the as unpopular
as
one could imagine but he he chose to do
it because it was the right thing to do
and Barack Obama pulled out of Iraq a
war that we had already won because he
had campaigned on it he knew it was an
easy an easy political decision for him
and for his base the then chose to go
into a war in Afghanistan the vast
majority of deaths in Afghanistan were
under his watch because he had
campaigned on that being the good war it
was always questions of expediency when
it came to Barack Obama and there was
courage when it came to George W Bush
but moving away from both of those guys
Alicia
Mitt Romney famously was pilloried for
saying in 2012 that the United States is
greatest geopolitical threat is Russia
Barack Obama said that the Muslim
terrorists do not pose an existential
threat to the United States where does
Muslim terrorism rank on all of the
global threats that we face I think
radical Muslim terrorism and Isis
specifically still ranks as number one
even though we have the prime minister
of Iraq and you know people leaders in
Iran saying oh we've eradicated Isis
they're out of here not true just four
hours ago German authorities released
details that they have made an arrest
that they think was the leader of a
terror cell that came directly from
Syria and had we in george w bush's
defense by the way had he been in power
during the Arab Spring I know he would
have handled it better and differently
had he been in power during the fall of
you know the Egyptian leader and the
rise of the Muslim Brotherhood they're
different they're also now we're dealing
with Bashar al-assad who is meeting with
Putin and super chummy
so Mitt Romney was right not only is he
a decent human being he was absolutely
right on the geopolitical field of what
was going to happen and how dangerous
Russia is you know they're assisting
China who's assisting North Korea
they're assisting you know Assad in
Syria who is this who's very dangerous
for the reason region committing
genocide against his own people and all
those countries are assisting Iran this
is a problem and I really hope that you
know our Secretary of State general
mattis I'm a big fan of and president
Truong getting down to business and do
something about it very quickly but one
has to rank priorities because sometimes
these foreign policy threats conflict so
you would you would
radical Islam as the is the greatest
threat is a greater threat than Russia
you say well tied because Russia is
feeding into radical Islam so it is a
threat for sure I think I think that
Isis attacks on Western civilization all
over the world is a massive threat but
they are being fed by the likes of
Russia and there is an existential
threat here I mean it depends if Russia
appears to have a relationship with
Bashar Assad but Bashar Assad has no
fondness for Isis or other Islamist
groups that threaten his power in Syria
the thing that Putin and Bashar Assad
have in common is that they they are
fond of themselves and that's about it
definitely I'm definitely of the nikki
Haley mindset here that if you know if
we're using the excuse that Assad is
gonna help us defeat Isis he ain't the
kind of guide to invite to be on our
team well it's it's hard there are
always challenges between more
idealistic foreign policies and more
realpolitik foreign policies and there's
a strain of this in conservatism we've
been grappling with what to do between
these four all of the history of
conservatism and moves one way during
george w bush it's a different way under
Nixon it's a different way under Reagan
maybe Reagan fuses the two together but
a difficult situation and the one thing
I think we can all agree on is that
Barack Obama was dead wrong about it
because there are existential threats to
our civilization and our way of life and
it's not just about who controls some
piece of the Middle East it's about
ideas and it's about attacking the
foundations of civilizations that
sometimes come into conflict all right
we need to get on to the news we have a
lot of news but we haven't talked about
sex once today I don't think this is the
longest we've gone without talking about
sex talk about that when I'm on the
panel here we go I'm about to get
Weinstein's
get my throne marshal throw out the
bathtub rub bath I blew it the bathroom
not the bathtub keep that in there we we
have to talk about all of this sex we
have to talk about many other wonderful
stories we're going to attack Harvard a
little bit we're going to talk about sex
BOTS we're gonna talk about Shaun King
being a dum-dum but unfortunately if you
are subscribed only on Facebook in
YouTube you can't see the rest of the
show you have to go to daily wire.com
and subscribe and then you get the whole
rest of the show
you'll get no ads on the website you'll
get me at the end reclaim and show you
get the Ben Shapiro show yada yada yada
thank you to everyone who already
subscribes but you're always listening
to this anyway I appreciate it you for
keeping the lights on for those of you
who are not yet let me try to convince
you huh I've got three words buddy
leftist tears tumblr there it is with
Isis in ruins the left the Obama era
tears that got people who said he was
going to institute a new world peace he
was going to make the world love us they
are gonna be gushing tears and you are
gonna need a vessel to contain all of
them that's why you need to go to daily
wired.com right now we'll be right back
[Music]
all right back to sex finally finally
this is this whole week the whole last
two weeks is just sex sex sex I guess
that's fine by me it's scintillating
enough to read the news
Al Franken as you know is under fire
there was another allegation against him
that he groped a woman's derriere during
the State Fair he I know I know I really
like it when these guys who were so
sanctimonious about sex then it turns
out that they are kind of creepy
themselves so in typical fashion
Saturday Night Live liberal women
empowered feminists what did they do
when they found out their former
colleague has been groping women they
issued a statement of support for Al
Franken
they supported Frank they don't believe
his accusers or they don't care about
his accusers they are just supporting
their buddy because they're totally full
of it speaking of people who are totally
full of it on the issue of sexual
deviancy we have to talk about Charlie
Rose Charlie Rose has been fired he's
that droning slothy zombie who's at CBS
and gives terrible interviews because he
doesn't know anything about the people
that he's interviewing and might not
have ever read a whole book in his life
Charlie Rose has been fired for multiple
sexual harassment scandals apparently
people have known about this this
producer have known about this forever
and just to refresh your memory here is
Steve Steve Rose Charlie Rose
grandstanding on the issue of sexual
assault and naughty language - Steve
Bannon just a few months ago they do
care about values and they do care about
respect for women it's not just locker
room talk it's locker room talk the
Billy Bush thing is locker room talking
by the way we have we have a but you
agree the empirical evidence to prove
this Democrat rep let's just point this
at John Conyers is also denying sexual
harassment claims as we speak I assume
since we started the show another 12 or
15 Democrat congressman have been
accused of sexual harassment we'll try
to update you as I checked Twitter
during the questions section Alicia what
is going on this is really really weird
I obviously we've been talking about
this a lot over the last two weeks
what has spurred this crazy era we've
seen it trickling a little
a bit with Cosby we know the individual
incidents but culturally from a bigger
level why are we all grappling with
sexual assault right now I think that
really to her credit gretchen carlson
when she came forward against roger
ailes it was something that the
mainstream media was like oh my god this
is amazing we can try to take down Fox
News they obviously failed there and
credit to Gretchen for coming forward
publicly megyn kelly and other women at
fox or a brave and came forward as well
and I think that once the mainstream
media saw that this like you used the
word titillating and interesting and
increase their clicks it increased their
ratings they they were the the blood was
in the water and they were pouncing and
ready for more I do think that there is
an aspect of women you know as they hear
other women come forward they become
more comfortable with coming forward and
sharing their stories credit to Leeanne
tweet and these other people for doing
this the Conyers thing by the way is
just atrocious I think our very own
Amanda
Preston giacomo wrote a really great
piece that outlines how our taxpayer
dollars have been settling HR and ethics
and sexual violent sexual assault
complaints in Congress for years our tax
dollars have been covering these guys
butts for their crappy behavior and I
don't know I mean even my liberal
girlfriends I think would be able to get
on board with saying our tax dollars
should not be covering that you and I
have been paying out hush money to cover
up Democrat sexual deviance in fairness
there are sexual deviants on both sides
of the aisle but recently we're seeing
the spate of Democrats but Bradley is
there something in the air I was talking
to Andrew Clavin about this last night
he thinks what we're seeing is the end
of the Clinton era that if Bill Clinton
were if Hillary Clinton had been elected
and Bill Clinton were in the White House
right now none of this would be
happening because then there would be
uncomfortable questions about the First
Gentleman and ironic title if ever there
were one is that what we're seeing are
we seeing the end of clintonism this
Clinton break for women's progress or is
it something else
I think that hopefully I could be wrong
about this that the mainstream media is
figuring out that if they actually want
to be pro women's rights they can't be
for anyone who has committed sexual
assault regardless of their political
affiliation and it's funny because now
the mainstream
adopting conservative standards that if
you are acting sexually immoral you
should be removed from whatever position
of power you have and it's refreshing to
me to know that all of these individuals
are older individuals within these
political and media spheres and
hopefully my generation in our
generation will be able to come forward
and push candidates and push individuals
and politicians that are moral and act
with respect for women in every aspect
you give them more credit than I do I
don't think there's anything high-minded
about their realizations I don't think
they suddenly woke up one day and said
ah I know the way to advance women's
rights is to attack those scumbags that
we've been covering for for two decades
I think maybe I'm a little jaded or a
little cynical but I think it's because
they've been attacking Roy Moore Bill
Clinton the big albatross on sexual
issues for Democrats is finished
he's totally done and I think they
realized the only way we can continue to
attack guys like Roy Moore is if we
clean a little bit of house ourselves
amber tell me that I'm too jaded and too
cynical or are we heading into a new
Victorian era I 100% agree with you
actually I think as soon as this stuff
about Roy Moore came out a lot of
conservatives myself included were
critiquing the media asking why didn't
you do this for people like Bill Clinton
why didn't you do this for all the
people that you've been covering for for
all of these years and they started to
realize if their claims against Roy
Moore we're going to be credible then
they had to go out and clean out
basically clean house of all of these
abusers that have been sitting at news
desks with them for years and I know
that this is true because just last week
our excuse me last year during the
presidential election the media ran
defense for Bill Clinton whenever it was
brought up in relation to Donald Trump
they always shut down whatever pundit
was on TV with them they called the
allegations against him discredited and
those are the same the same exact
language that people use to defend
Donald Trump so the media started to
wise up and realize well look if the if
conservatives are going to be on
with us attacking people like Donald
Trump and Roy Moore then we're going to
have to finally come out events against
bachlin and by the way it doesn't
actually matter anymore anyway because
he's not in power yeah it's over I think
they for a while it was more important
to them to keep Bill Clinton than to hit
Republican sexual deviants but now that
that Clinton's over it's much more fun
for them to attack Trump or Roy Moore I
also think that you've seen the tides
turn specifically and we talked about
this the other day millennial women
voters even the liberal ones didn't get
out and vote for Hillary Clinton because
they did care about the Bill Clinton
aspect and you have been pointed it out
on his podcast a couple days ago and I
think he is accurate and saying it's
interesting that all of these reports
that we're seeing typically tend to be
these dirty old men there has been thank
God a generational change where men
don't do this anymore or they realize
that it's not appropriate in the
workplace anymore and so you don't
really have that many Generation Xers or
Millennials that are going out there and
doing this kind of stuff in the
workplace Alicia give them time those
dirty dogs I'm done wait till they turn
60 right yeah they're young and
good-looking now just wait until they
get old and creepy I'm less awful than
you are I think all right enough about
sex for now don't worry we'll get back
to sex we'll go back to the all the sex
spots later on but first let's make fun
of Harvard a little bit the DOJ is
currently investigating Harvard
University first University in the
country for racial discrimination in its
admissions practices because of
affirmative action specifically they're
talking about discrimination against
Asian American students who are applying
and being disadvantaged because Asian
American students on average do very
well on tests and there have been de
facto quotas at universities for decades
now so often we hear about the side of
affirmative action that gives people an
unfair advantage so students who come
from either poor places or because of
the color of their skin or where they
come from or whatever they get a little
boost when it comes to college
applications very rarely are we willing
to consider the logically necessary flip
side of that coin which is that students
who are more qualified who have on just
on paper better applications will be
disadvantaged if you give someone else
an advantage for another reason Alicia
is there any reason in 2017 to continue
the practice of affirmative action in
college admissions I think that it is
damaging and now we're at typically
seeing that I think the next generation
I'm sorry I'm all about generation say
I've just been reading lots of studies
about them but you had talked a couple
weeks ago to Kristin's old suits
anderson about the Generation Z right
they're the best
and they're potentially gonna be really
the best and I think that the
Conservatives have an opportunity to win
them over politically but in addition to
that they're the most racially diverse
and they're now going to be majority
minority most of them come from mixed
families most of them come from what
typically was minority families and what
it for every other generation in the
United States and so really when you
look at the beauty of America and the
melting pot that we have become just
hold everybody to the same standards and
we've seen that Harvard isn't the only
one that's done this there are some
professors that came out a couple years
ago at UCLA that had said during the
admissions process they knew that people
in the admissions department would see
an Asian last name and they
automatically deduct SAT points or not
pay as much attention to that students
essay because they suspected that the
Asian students IQ was going to be better
than that of a Hispanic or an
african-american or even a white
Caucasian student that's just ridiculous
let's like stop looking at people's
names
let's stop assuming their ethnicities
and let's get down to the brass tacks of
are they qualified and able to go to
that school or not but but then of
course the lefties won't be able to hang
on to their favorites that's right yeah
that's right that's right amber is there
you know 25 years ago when Sandra Day
O'Connor upheld maybe a little bit less
when the Supreme Court upheld
affirmative action Sandra Day O'Connor
wrote and said that over time it would
become less important to have
affirmative action and eventually it
would be ruled unconstitutional or done
away with it was almost admitting that
it's unconstitutional but it simply was
being upheld to correct some historic
wrong as that time now come is it
important in the upcoming Supreme Court
sessions that we overturn or deem
unconstitutional affirmative action
policies I think it has common as Alicia
said
upcoming generation is one of the most
racially diverse I'm in what end the
generation that has some of the most
opportunities available to them and I
think affirmative action is especially
damaging in the sense that it admits
people who aren't qualified for
universities and ultimately is just
setting them up to fail so the Liberals
sort of push this policy as some kind of
kind gesture in order to give
disadvantaged groups opportunities but
is actually very cruel in the sense that
you're admitting these people who are
probably going to fail out their
freshman year or they're not going to
make it through the four years they're
wasting money's on the education system
only to leave without a degree I
actually read a piece in the Georgetown
student newspaper yesterday that's where
I went to school and there was a student
they had admitted who finished his
junior year of high school with a 1.5
GPA and Georgetown is supposed to be a
prestigious university and you can guess
what happened the student failed two
classes his freshman year and then ended
up having to take a year off for health
issues and he's not even sure if he's
going to graduate so I think it's really
disappointing to see liberals claiming
kindness when really they're just
harming these people and damaging them
financially to the road to hell is paved
with good intentions and there is what
you're talking about is mismatch theory
Scalia was called a racist for bringing
this up but it's a well substantiated
theory which is that if a university
admits somebody who isn't qualified then
they're not going to excel there maybe
they'll graduate but they won't do very
well and that will follow them
throughout their lives whereas actually
sorry no well it's happening in law
schools as well and there's actually
studies that have come out that have
shown that minority students are passing
the bar at much lower rates and it's
mainly because less qualified applicants
are being admitted through affirmative
action programs it's it's really no good
because if you go to a school that
you're qualified for then you have a
chance of doing well there in succeeding
and moving up an academic ladder or a
professional ladder but if you're
constantly failing it's very difficult
to pull yourself back up there's also a
realization that you know sometimes and
this coming from the college dropout
here
ended up working in tuk radio and now is
still in media so maybe I haven't done
the college dropouts have talked to talk
radio and it done very well and that not
as successful as Russian Sean but thanks
for that but I think that we need to
come to the realization too is that kids
cannot be whatever they want to be i
think mike road hit a video about this
over at Prager University maybe kids
shouldn't follow their passion you might
want to feel like you should be an
attorney and debate and argue before the
Supreme Court one day but you also might
not be able to cut it so you should
figure out a profession that you're
actually decent at that's gonna pay you
for the rest of your life you know it
might be this thing that we've been told
since we were kids you can be whatever
you want to be you can do whatever you
want that has maybe led to this moment
where a little boy thinks that he can
become a big grown woman or vice versa
but again we are limited by in part our
biology by our circumstances by time and
space and unfortunately I will never be
a ballerina no matter how much I try
let's get to sex spots are you ready to
talk about sex spots it's been it's been
almost 35 seconds since we last talked
about sex the sex spot demand has been
skyrocketing around the world there are
brothels across Europe that are now
firing women and just hiring plastic
dolls the men would prefer the dolls
according to porn star Harriet
sugar-cookie I think that's her
Christian name she said you can get
almost anything you want it's a fantasy
a doll with three boobs no problem elf
ears sure a cat tail why not and they
make them look super realistic I'm just
gonna take a moment and think about that
yeah that's very very strange very hard
to process don't know that I can three
boobs a cat tail and elf ears
Alicia what is your expert here what
your are you know on this question of
artificial sex versus real sex virtual
sex versus real people is the culture
moving toward a fake reality toward an
illusion is it is that the essence of
the sex pots or is it just that perverts
can't find women to fulfill their
fantasies it's like a mix of Hunger
Games meets brave new world meets a book
that hasn't even
written yet and probably shouldn't be I
never thought I would defend the
profession of the oldest profession in
the world but I mean these poor women
getting like talk about the fight for 15
in minimum wage a new McDonald's was
replacing cashiers with robots but now
apparently hookers are being replaced by
them two things real tough in that
business it's really hard with
industrialization like this I just I
kind of am like if you're gonna be the
creeper the creepy creepy creeper that
doesn't just want a hooker but wants a
robot hooker you go do your thing and us
conservatives will be fruitful and
multiply
and then we're gonna eventually take
over the world this is my only hope for
the future and I will keep repeating it
and beating that drum forever Bradley I
think you're the youngest guy on this
panel you're one of those Jen's ears
maybe maybe you're at the end of the
Millennials what is it about the removal
from real people you know I know now all
of dating happens on a phone you just
swipe there's a lot of texting in the
old days in my day that wasn't the case
they're obviously porn is on the rise
globally among younger and younger
people there was a study that came out
that one in 10 teenagers under 18 have
tried anal sex with a partner of the
opposite sex I think it's three and ten
by twenty five these kids are getting
kind of weird and kinky but it's also
less real it's also more digital it's
also more virtual what does that say
about the dating scene why are people
substituting illusion for the real thing
I think it's superficial and it's based
on instant gratification women won't
necessarily give you exactly what you
want when you want it and so you need a
robot to do it sadly apparently and I
think that this trend is very clear in
Japan where if you look at your hands
population in the 1990s it looked like a
Christmas tree but now it's starting to
look like a spinning top and it's
because Japanese women are actually
turning towards erotic apps because
Japanese men can't connect to them on a
personal level and so Japanese men are
turning towards video games and sex
robots and coincidentally those sex
robots look like Christmas trees with on
spinning tops which is really weird now
you would never expect exactly a
Christmas tree with three spinning tops
and a cat
don't forget don't forget the elephant's
yeah you know I almost want my Spock
ears on the show but I thought it was
gonna be a little too nerdy yeah I I
just pray that America doesn't fall into
this trap I think that we saw the movie
called her or he falls into falls in
love with a Siri character played by
Scarlett Johansson or something like
that and I just pray that we keep in
mind that instant gratification isn't
the way to build a proper society I mean
if you look at the polarization of
politics and sensationalization of media
it's had effects in the political realm
and I hope that we don't take that to
our beds well I don't know I always
think about politics in the bedroom
amber there it to be devil's advocate
people who are saying that these sex
dolls aren't just the end of human
existence they're saying that it's a
good outlet for perverts to indulge
their sexual fantasies without hurting
people
pedophiles for instance if you have
sexual fantasies about children then you
can use one of these little dolls and
then you don't have to hurt a child does
that argument hold water or no god no I
mean who is the person that's making a
child sex doll pretty rich in certain
parts of the world apparently but I
don't know maybe we'll pass laws against
it yeah I mean I think this whole thing
is rather disturbing and I'm gonna be
really original here and blame liberals
for this because I think a lot of this I
think a lot of this comes out of these
sort of like free love anything-goes
movement where liberals have told people
for years and years that you can indulge
whatever your weird sexual desires are
and nobody can judge you for it and now
and we've always said that there were
some things that people should be judged
for like pedophilia and now apparently
we're at the point where well we're
gonna judge you but we're also going to
provide an outlet for your weird desires
so everything is spiraling downhill into
this sexual degeneracy and I think it
also just causes people not to value
human relationships and human sexual
relationships as much which leads to the
sexual harassment culture so everything
goes full search it just feeds the lust
it just feeds the sin yeah Alicia
you brought up these poor iTNOW
impoverished prostitutes who are seeing
their their wages go down isn't there
something to be said though that
prostitution is a vicious and terrible
industry that's why we have laws against
it as we don't want women who are
desperate to fall into this abusive
industry with if there are sex dolls for
men to go and have their fun with won't
that create an incentive to get rid of
prostitution and won't that be good for
women is it is it possible that like
both are bad and both are demoralizing
an awful for society and we should maybe
say hey the buck stops here like we
don't want this done at all
but if you had to make a choice if you
had to say we have a world in which
because that's really what's being posed
by the sexbots if they're really
spreading if they're really shutting
down brothels are the sexbots better
than the than the prostitute so then
prostitution for women you know if
wishes were fishes we'd all be swimming
in riches but it is a fallen world if
you had to choose one sort of decadence
and debauchery
would you take the robots or the
real-life hookers why why are you doing
this to me I don't like this question at
all
I say neither neither neither can i I
mean yeah not amber Bradley any thoughts
it's like 2016 Michael don't do the
binary choice again there was also a
good decision then it's been a pretty
good year as we just talked about Isis
being defeated amber are you going to
take a stand against sex robots no are
you gonna I am really curious about this
question because I think there's an
unwillingness to deal with it we can say
well we should outlaw the sex robots and
we should keep prostitution illegal well
you know they're both bad things but it
poses a real question for society it's
very easy for conservatives to say that
pornography is bad and virtual sex is
bad and yada yada yada
but is it possible that there is
something good that might come out of it
which would be the protection of women
in desperate circumstances maybe I think
the problem though is that if you rely
on the the sex robots like I said you
take away the human interaction from
people they start to value human
relation
chips less and when they do get into
human relationships I think they're more
likely to act improperly or abuse those
people because they haven't been taught
what the rules are so I don't like this
would you rather game either that's a
great point and CS Lewis brings this up
when he talks about animal cruelty he
says the reason not to abuse animals is
not because the animals have some rights
or something but because it makes you
crueler it Dell defens your humanity it
dulls your humanity and certainly that
that's the moral hazard with you know
weird sex robots or something is it to
the greatest extreme makes you view
people as objects you are literally
objectifying people and that that can't
be good for your own Humanity we're
gonna end on an excellent tweet just a
tweet that personifies that it totally
embodies left-wing activism in 2017
Shaun King the BLM activist who recently
blocked me on Twitter because i quoted
his own words at him
Shaun King sent out a tweet and he said
ungrateful is the new N word the word
ungrateful because Donald Trump called
levar Baal ungrateful after his child
was released from that Chinese jail
because of because of Donald Trump's
machinations with the Chinese government
and so Shaun King said this was a racist
statement and ungrateful as the new
n-word now it's worth pointing out that
Donald Trump is also called Chelsea
Manning ungrateful and called rapper Mac
Miller not only ungrateful but an
ungrateful dog both of whom are white
people Amber is ungrateful the new
n-word are these racist dog whistles
coming out of the White House no
obviously not I as with a lot of donald
trump's feets i think it was maybe a
little bit tone-deaf not in the sense
that it was racist at all but just that
it was kind of not very presidential but
i mean what else is new but on the other
side of the coin you have this weird
theme where Donald Trump did a really
great thing and got through UCL Basques
UCLA basketball players out of a Chinese
prison and the father of one of them has
been incredibly unkind to the the person
who basically saved his
so no I don't think it's a racial thing
and I actually saw a hot take on CNN
yesterday where one of their guests said
that Donald Trump is unwilling to attack
white met on Twitter and I'm sure all of
us could probably name like 10 white men
each nice they do accuse this they often
say that the word thug is now a
euphemism for the n-word you probably
saw this during the Ferguson riots and
and the black lives matter Sommers
Bradley are these euphemisms or is it
okay to call a thug a thug and an
ingrate and ingrate
well actually I'm taking a class that's
political justice and it's basically
Reagan bashing 101 and they kind of lay
out the narrative on why the Nixon and
Reagan administration's actually we're
using the n-word when they were using
all these euphemisms like we're gonna be
tough on crime we're going to be tough
on thugs and things like that and it's
not convincing but the problem is we're
seeing a growing divide in Republicans
and Democrats on this appeal research a
study came out that says there was a 50
point difference between Republicans and
Democrats when they asked the question
that racial discrimination is the main
reason why many black people can't get
ahead these days and we're in 2017 we're
60 years out of Jim Crow but then you
see Netflix documentary documentaries
like the 13 saying that no matter what
we do our criminal justice system will
always be conflating criminality with
the antler so I think that it's smart
labeling by the left to get their
narrative out there and to attract a
large bloc of voters in American society
but no it's it's not complaining people
who commit crimes with African Americans
and if you insist that African Americans
and people who commit crimes are the
same than you and your self you are
making a racist argument
Alicia you are an insightful commentator
but Shaun King is not why does anybody
care what this guy thinks oh gosh who
knows because you know he was a head of
black lives matter and isn't he
over at the young turks or some
progressive yeah Turkey a New York Times
all the same
who knows they're all the same but it's
just like it's the do as I say not as I
do and I'm sorry I I tend to agree with
my black friends who say I don't use
that word I am a woman the B word could
be used to describe me and sometimes
especially when I'm cutting lanes on the
101 but who you know I still don't use
that word toward myself or my
girlfriends and I would expect black
people to do the same just this
everything about trumping racists it's
like come on guys I didn't even vote for
the guy he's not my favorite person in
the world but you're really reaching
here I mean the the latest thought
yesterday was that apparently he's
racist now because the two turkeys that
he's going to be pardoning on
Thanksgiving Day or white it's like
Poe's law in action it's so absurd that
you can't tell if it's parody it feels
true with this administration though and
the mainstream media is and left its
reaction to it it's like wait is is this
Babylon be like it's a joke but no it is
not unbelievable true and you know
speaking of those euphemisms is someone
of Sicilian descent anyone could use the
T word about me and I'll leave it to
those well-read italian scholars to know
what the T word is but you know it's
okay man I don't complain about it
because I'm grateful I'm especially
grateful for you panel of deplorable 'z
have a very happy Thanksgiving if I
don't talk to you tomorrow
Bradley Devlin amber Athey and Alicia
crass The Daily wire zone thank you for
being here grateful that guy levar ball
was ungrateful and there's so much to be
grateful for right now we've defeated
Isis the economy is booming foreign
policy is back on track deregulation at
huge government agencies massive
deregulation New York Times is
complaining about it almost every day
we've got tax reform on the table great
originalist justices all the way up at
the Supreme Court and being nominated to
the lower courts this is pretty good
there's a lot to be thankful for this
Thanksgiving and I'm thankful for you
okay
come back tomorrow we have got a really
fun Thanksgiving Day special that we're
going to be running the real history of
Thanksgiving and why it's evidence of
God's providence for the Pilgrims I'll
be talking about my form a
our ancestors some of whom were great
really virtuous pious guys and one of
whom was the first criminal executed in
the new the New World in that colony so
doing it tomorrow I'm like Knowles's in
my own old show come back tomorrow we'll
do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael nul show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017